let me introduce the first keeper lewis
and lewis is a machine and learning
engineer attacking phase focused on
developing open source stores and making
them accessible to the wider community
and is also the culture of an upcoming
already book on transformers that you
should definitely read
and today you will talk to us about how
easy it is to start training with the
aging phase transformers trainer
so let's go out of the way and i'll show
we'll show your talk
g'day this is louis from hugging face
and today i'm going to be talking to you
about the trainer in the transformers
library
now you probably encountered this
subject in part one of the course but if
it's the first time you've ever heard of
the trainer don't worry i'll explain
what it's all about so as you can
probably guess by the name the trainer
is for training models
and what it does is it provides a high
level abstraction
to simplify all of the kind of
boilerplate code that you typically have
to write when you make your own training
loops
in deep learning
so
what you provide in addition to a model
are data sets you provide some hyper
parameters some metrics
and it takes all of this and then gives
you some methods that let you train
evaluate and make predictions using the
same object
so
there's a couple of times where maybe
you don't want to use a trainer the
first one is that the trainer is based
on pytorch
so if you're not using pytorch you're
going to need to
check out for example matt's video where
he shows you how to train transformers
using keras and tensorflow
the other case is where sometimes your
logic can be very specific or you need
some fine grained control over the
training loop and in those cases you
should use the accelerate library which
sylvan is also talking about today so
you should check out his talk as well
okay with that let's dive in and look at
how the trainer works
so
to get started we need a data set and
the data set i've picked today is called
the emotion data set which is a data set
of tweets which have been given or
labeled with a different set of emotions
ranging from things like joy to anger or
disgust so we can pull this data set
from the hub using the load dataset
function
and you can see here that we've got
three splits and we've got a fair amount
of data to play with we've got 16 000
examples to train on so this is a pretty
good sized data set for fine tuning
now if we look inside
the first element of the training set
you'll see that in the datasets library
every kind of row is represented as a
dictionary
by default and
the values or say the columns of this
data set are represented as the keys and
the values are the actual values of the
rows
but you know a lot of the time when i'm
doing this kind of initial exploration
or trying to understand you know
can i visualize some aspects of the data
i usually prefer doing this in pandas
it's a little bit more flexible for this
kind of application
so the cool thing about the datasets
library is it lets
us switch easily between these different
formats and one way to do that is to
just apply the two pandas function
to the data set and voila we now have a
data frame
so cool we can see in the data frame
we've got some tweets
and we've got some labels which are
presumably the emotions but it's not
super obvious you know what these
numbers really mean
so
a very
quick way to figure out what's going on
is to inspect the features of the
dataset
so
the features will tell us what data
types are being used for each column in
the data set
so you can see here that the text column
is basically a string as we would expect
but the label column is something
special called a class label data type
so this class label data type
it has some special features it has some
attributes for example we can see that
already there are the names of of the
emotions here
but what i really want to know is what
are the relationships between like
numbers like 0 3 and 2 and the actual
names
and this class label
data type has a function called into
string which does that for us
so here it says
the label id 0 is corresponding to
sadness
and so what i can do is i can create a
mapping
that just relates every single label id
to the corresponding label name so here
i've just created a dictionary
using this interstring function
and now we know
that for example 0 sadness 5 for
surprise and everything in between
and we while we're at it we can also go
the other way around and provide the
relationship of the name to the id
and the reason i'm creating these
mappings is because when we do
text classification with transformers
it's really useful if we provide these
mappings to the model so that then when
we want to do inference
instead of just getting a prediction of
a zero a three or a two we actually get
a prediction for the actual name of the
emotion so this is a really common thing
that we're going to need to provide to
the model and it's always good to do it
straight up
now the other thing i do in text
classification problems is i just
inspect the distribution of classes like
what are the frequencies
so in pandas you can do this with the
value counts method
and what you can see is that the data
set is very imbalanced so for example
the
label or the class 0
which is sadness is represented roughly
um through the data
the same is true for joy so that's
another third of the data
has been labeled as joy but then like
the last one which is surprise has only
you know been given the label or there
are only roughly four percent of the
tweets are actually given the surprise
label
so if we train a model just kind of
naively on this distribution
uh one problem that can happen is that
the model will just
get very good at predicting these
majority classes
but it will struggle a lot on these rare
classes and so if these classes are
important for some application that
you're building you're going to have
some sort of inferior performance on
those now there's a couple of techniques
that people
use to handle this
the first one is to kind of modify the
data itself
so for example we could
up sample the rare classes by just
duplicating
um the examples until we get kind of an
even distribution
but the downside with that is that deep
learning models like transformers are
really good at memorizing or you know
discovering patterns in the data and so
if we duplicate a lot of examples
then probably the model is going to kind
of memorize those duplicates and when it
sees examples from that class in
production it's actually not going to
generalize very well
so what we're going to do today is we're
actually going to
modify the loss function
of the model during training
and this will allow us to then
kind of introduce a bias directly at the
level of loss function
which indicates you know these are the
way that the classes are distributed and
hopefully this will encourage the model
to pay more attention to these rare
classes
but before we jump into that let's uh
just prepare our data set
and you probably remember that the first
thing
you need to do in most nlp problems is
tokenize the data so that it gets into a
format that's suitable for training
and the model i'm going to use today is
called mini lm
now
if you go to the model hub there are
thousands of models
here you can see that there's roughly 32
000 models this is not all the public
models it includes private ones as well
but in any case you can see that bert
bass is currently the most popular model
on the hub
and that's maybe not so surprising
because burt was like the first
transformer that really you know took
over nlp
but you know
the field moves fast and this model may
be kind of outdated
and to kind of
show you that
there's a really interesting paper
called mini lm by microsoft
and they showed that
you can take a kind of burp model and
you can compress it into a smaller
version
called mini-lm
and so here you can see that bert has
roughly 110 million parameters
and they were able to reduce this to 66
million parameters so almost half the
size
but the cool thing is that if you look
at the performance
mini lm
averaged over all these kind of poor nlp
benchmarks only really drops one
percentage point compared to bert
you know which is quite impressive it's
roughly twice as fast because it's twice
as small but it barely loses any uh
performance
so
my advice is maybe don't use bert don't
reach for burt the first time maybe pick
one of these
faster and you know models like mini lm
or distilbert and you'll typically find
that you can then iterate much faster in
your experiments because you know
they're faster to train
so i'm going to use the minieln model
and i just pick
the pre-trained checkpoint from the hub
now once we have our tokenizer we can
feed in an example and we can see that
okay we're now getting input ids so
these are like the sort of tokenized
inputs that we're going to feed to the
model
we have token type ids which are kind of
common with burp models to indicate
whether we have a
you know sentence one or sentence two
and then there's the attention mask
which is used to indicate you know which
tokens correspond to padding or not
but this is all covered in part one of
the course so go check that out if this
is unfamiliar
but the thing that we want to do is we
want to apply this tokenizer to all the
examples in the dataset
and the datasets library
provides a map method which is a
powerful way of just providing a
function and applying that function to
all the examples
so here what i'm doing is i've defined a
function called tokenized text which
will take some inputs
it will tokenize them just as we did
before
and the other thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to truncate
any of the long examples
because every transformer model has a
maximum sequence size it can process
and by specifying the truncation we can
then ensure that we don't get any errors
during training
so if i go ahead and do that
i'll get now
a tokenized data set and you can see
that indeed we've now added some new
columns sorry the input ids and circuit
type ids which correspond to the
objects that we want to use
you know during training
so without further ado let's think about
you know how do we handle this question
of class and balance
so the way we could do this is we can
say okay in the data there's some
frequency distribution
and i'm going to then introduce some
kind of weights or let's say
coefficients for the loss function which
will multiply each one of those classes
by an amount that's reflected in the
data
and if we demand that these coefficients
range from 0 to 1 then intuitively we
might say assign a high weight to the
rare classes and a low weight to the
common classes so this way the model
doesn't get kind of too biased on the
majority classes
so what we can do is we can
use our trusty value counts function
from pandas
and so if we subtract the frequency from
one
and then normalize this by the total
number of samples
then this will provide us with this kind
of coefficients which go from zero to
one just as we wanted
so if we do that we can see that okay
the first class which was one of the
popular ones i think it was sadness has
been normalized to be multiplied by 0.7
during training
while the
one of the sort of rare classes which
was a surprise has now a much higher
coefficient so this will hopefully boost
the signal
during training
and
because the trainer is based on pi torch
we ultimately want all of these weights
to be torch tensors so i'm just going to
convert this from a numpy array into a
torch tensor and while we're at it we're
going to put it on the gpu because
that's ultimately you know where we want
to do the training
and just one last thing
to sort of
take note of is that
the trainer you need to indicate kind of
which column
corresponds to the targets in this case
the labels
and in particular if we look at the
documentation
we can see that
your model can compute the loss if a
label's argument is provided so what i'm
going to do
is i'm going to rename the label column
to labels and then we'll be good to go
okay so
we now have
the ingredients we need to define our
trainer
and what i'm doing here is i'm going to
create a custom trainer so that we can
do this kind of custom loss computation
so in the documentation
what we're told is that if you want to
inject custom behavior into the training
loop you can subclass any of these
methods here
and then input any sort of logic that
you want
and so the one that we're interested in
is the compute loss method because we
want to compute our loss function
and so what i'm doing here is i'm just
creating a new class called the weighted
loss trainer i'm subclassing the trainer
and i just need to then input my logic
to compute this weighted loss so the way
we can do this is we can feed the inputs
to the model to get the outputs
we can then extract from these outputs
the logits
which is what we ultimately wanted to
compare with the labels we get the
labels
and then in pi torch there's a loss
function called cross entropy loss where
you can provide an actual weight
corresponding to these class weights
that we computed earlier
and once we have our loss function we
can then compute the loss directly
and we just need to return
um you know the loss if the function
just returns loss by itself or in some
cases we also need to return the model
outputs and that's indicated here by
this return outputs flag
so now we've got our trainer we can just
go ahead and fill in the missing pieces
that we need
and those missing pieces are kind of
described in this diagram here
so we need to provide a model we need to
provide the data sets we need hyper
parameters and metrics so let's go ahead
and add these remaining pieces
so
we can instantiate a model using the
from pre-trained method and because
we're dealing with text classification
we're going to treat this as a sequence
classification task
and here you can see that in addition to
the pre-trained checkpoint that we use
for the tokenizer i'm also providing the
number of labels that are associated
with the dataset and also the mappings
from the label ids to the label names
so this will instantiate the model
then we need to metrics and here i'm
using the f1 score from scikit learn and
the reason for that is that if you're
dealing with imbalanced data
the accuracy will be biased towards the
majority class and give you kind of like
a false or inflated
score whereas the f1 score is sort of
like the mean of precision and recall
and this is a better way
of kind of trading off
these these are imbalances
so this function you would have seen in
part one but basically we extract the
labels and the predictions
we feed them into our metric and then we
just return a dictionary which has that
metric so that's pretty straightforward
and then the last thing we need to
provide are the hyper parameters so
here the main thing you need with the
training arguments is you need to
provide an output directory
which is going to save all the
checkpoints so the model the tokenizer
the configuration some other files
but we also can specify other things for
example the number of epochs we want to
train
the learning rate and one thing that's
really good to know is for example
whether you use mixed precision so if
your gpu supports mixed precision
training you should always use fp16 true
to make it go fast
and the last thing we want to do is we
want to push our model to the hub
during training so all the checkpoints
we can just push them automatically to
the hub with push to hub true
and you'll find that model
basically in the same location on your
account as the name of this output
directory and we'll see that in a minute
or so
so once we've got the model the hyper
parameters the metrics the data sets we
feed all of these into the trainer
and here it's just the same
signature that we would have used for a
vanilla trainer but we've now got our
custom trainer with our custom loss
and once we
instantiate the trainer it will create a
repository on the hanging face hub
it will then clone it and then
in our local directory we'll use that to
store all of these checkpoints during
training
so now we can train the model
and it's just a one-liner
and this takes around five minutes on my
gpu and you can see that during training
you know the loss has gone down which is
great and the f1 score has gone up so
you can see that after five epochs we
now get around 92 f1 score which is
great
um and we can then actually check out
our model um on the hub
and we can see that you know we've um
we've got like an inference widget so we
can for example uh inspect you know what
are the outputs um for some inputs so
here's some test which says you know i
like you i love you
and indeed we would expect this to be
about love that's what we see
um and we also have some information
about the training
um which was you know stored in the
trainer and then saved into the model
card so this is this is all you know
really useful information
um
now at the end of training you might
want to
use this model in your own application
and so for that you should use the
pipeline function
and so here we just provide to the
pipeline function the checkpoint that
we've created
we're doing text classification and once
you have that you can provide some text
and see what the outputs are yourself so
indeed if i'm really excited about part
two lagging face course this should be
joy
and
that's basically it we've created our
own trainer
um our own customer trainer by
overwriting some functions
and you know you should now have all the
tools you need to work on your own
projects i look forward to seeing you in
the forums and on discord
hello everyone welcome back sorry for
these technical difficulties
yeah sorry about that it should be
better right now we figured out a way to
to stream the videos without
[Music]
them being like with the sound
completely disconnected from the video
so thanks for your talk lewis
and we have a couple of questions for
you
the first one is
you use the datasets library in your
talk but can i use my own datasets with
the trainer
yes you can so
basically you can
actually use the datasets library to
load your own datasets
for example
if um you have your data set stored as a
csv file then the data sets library lets
you load this in in a good format and
then you can just tokenize this and feed
it into the trainer as you wish
but you could also if you wished um you
know use your own like sort of pie torch
data sets that would also um work i mean
silvan is the creator of the trainer so
he can always uh override me with true
wisdom
no that seems correct um another
question we had on the forums is um
you suggest changing belt base for many
lm as baseline pretrained model is very
analogous recommendation for
multilingual models which checkpoints
should be the go-to yeah that's a great
question so um this is certainly
something that i think happens almost
any time you're working outside of the
us and you have to deal with multiple
languages
and for me personally like a very strong
baseline for this is xlm roberta
it's a it's a model from facebook that
was trained on 100 languages in parallel
and it gets
quite good results and
it does better than for example
multilingual bert which was one of the
first multilingual transformers so
that's probably what i would use if i
was starting out
thanks
another question we have is
how can we debug
something when something goes wrong with
the trainer
well you should go to chapter eight of
the course and watch the video where
sylvan walks you step by step on how to
do this
um but you know in just to give you a
high level summary i mean it's a it's a
training kind of loop or pipeline and
there's several places things can go
wrong
so the first thing that you should
always check is is the data um in its
right format so a really common mistake
that i myself make almost all the time
is i forget to tokenize the data and
then you're just trying to feed strings
to the model and it gets confused
um another thing that can go wrong is
maybe the the name of your labels column
isn't right so you saw in the
tutorial i had to change this
to make it work kind of out of the box
um and then of course there's all the
cuda hell
of um you know things like out of memory
side assert errors all this garbage
and um they're the the great tip from
sylvan is to put the model on the cpu
because then you'll actually get a trace
back in python that tells you where the
you know which line of code the error is
actually coming from
so i would say those are kind of the
main things so check the data
put it on cpu and then you know have fun
another question that's linked to to the
technical difficulties
so during the technical glitch lewis
explains the weight heat loss can you
show it again so could you show your
screen and trade again because
apparently there are something that
people missed yeah sure let's do that
thanks a lot
okay so let's see you should be able to
see
this weighted loss trainer where is it
up here
yeah
um yeah so let me just like very quickly
say what i was trying to do here so um
basically in in the trainer you can
override various methods and the thing
that we wanted to do was to find a way
to kind of weight the loss according to
the distribution of classes in the data
so i had actually previously computed
the class weights
and what you can do then is just extract
the outputs from the model
to get the logits get the labels from
the data and then just compute the loss
using the standard cross-entropy loss
and then basically this function will
just return the loss and the model
outputs
if that's needed or just the loss by
itself
and yeah this shows you kind of how
simple it is to kind of customize the
trainer to do the things that you you
really want it to do
if you've got like a sort of task or
application that isn't supported out of
the box
does that answer the question silvan i
think so
so we had some other questions coming on
the forums while you were talking
is there a page in the docs a chapter in
the course an external resource with an
overview of different loss functions and
their advantage is disadvantages
that's a great question as far as i know
we don't have something like that in the
transformers docs
but that would actually be a great
community contribution so
if the person who asked that knows knows
the answer or wants to learn um it would
be really nice to have like a table in
the docs which explains like which loss
function is kind of optimal for um which
task
i would say that in general like for
most applications
uh fiddling with the loss function is
kind of the the latter
thing that you want to focus on it's
much more effective to
switch the architecture for example or
just
improve the data set if you're really
trying to squeeze performance out of out
of the task
but um yeah that's a really nice
community contribution
and one last question is
does the way the initialized model was
made as in made using tensorflow pytorch
affects its performance or cause any
issue
yeah that's a really uh deep question
because we actually know that like the
way that we initialize neural networks
has a long history of
people finding like different ways to
initialize it and get suddenly state of
the art
i would say that in the case of
transformers because we're kind of
building a head
that is randomly initialized on top of a
pre-trained body
most of the time this isn't a concern
you you can just train it and you'll get
some kind of fluctuation with each
training run but generally speaking
you'll see pretty stable results
the only time i've seen this actually be
a problem is if you have a lot of
classes so imagine i have like a
thousand classes or something like this
and suddenly in you know some of the
rare examples my model has only got like
three examples to to
to see in training and then you'll start
to see much greater fluctuation at the
per class level
and then what you can do is do multiple
training runs
and then kind of average the results to
get kind of a confidence
window over that
but yeah generally speaking you're good
to go and if you want to fix it you can
also set the seed in the trainer
[Music]
thanks a lot that's all the questions uh
people had